since the shooting we've heard about new
efforts to find common ground in
congress on gun legislation president
biden has also vowed to get involved
nancy cordes is at the white house nancy
good morning how is it going so far
well nate a bipartisan group of senators
held its first virtual meeting yesterday
to discuss a possible compromise on gun
reform the members say that their
staffers are going to keep talking but
it's still very unclear whether they'll
be able to bridge a gulf that has
existed for decades
this is a test of democracy connecticut
senator chris murphy said the two
democrats and two republicans were
covering a lot of ground in that virtual
meeting background checks red flag laws
safe gun storage and school security i
can't guarantee you that there will be a
compromise
but i think we will know one way or the
other you know by next week as to
whether we can achieve it one red flag
the senate's republican leader mitch
mcconnell didn't even list guns among
the problems highlighted by the uvalde
texas massacre mental illness
and school safety republicans have
proposed upping spending to harden
schools more cameras fewer doors
president biden doesn't agree it is not
something that he believes in some
states aren't waiting for washington new
york state democrats announced tuesday
they'll soon join five other states to
ban the sale of semi-automatic rifles to
people under 21. a shooter a mass
shooter it comes after an 18 year old
allegedly shot and killed 10 people at a
buffalo supermarket with the same ar-15
style weapon that the 18-year-old
juvalde shooter used at the white house
tuesday president biden hosted new
zealand prime minister jacinda ardern
her country banned all semi-automatic
weapons in 2019 after a gunman killed
more than 50 people at two mosques in
christchurch the new zealand public had
an expectation that if we knew what the
problem was that we that we do something
about that
house democrats are watching what's
happening in the senate but they are
moving ahead with their own massive
package of gun reforms it would raise
the purchasing age for semi-automatic
weapons to 21 it would also ban
high-capacity magazines but gail even if
that bill does pass the house it isn't
going to become law unless it has enough
senate support
i hear you nancy we need a hero somebody
needs to figure this out thank you very
much